foreign
[Music]
I'd like your opinion on our commercial
this commercial ends up being pretty
tame by 2023 standards I've paid to have
it aired during the Super Bowl being 1
000 years in the future and still
relying on vhsc this should be format
and if we send it in stranger things you
can bet you're a shiny metal ass we're
gonna send it here too also in the
history of man recordable media has
evolved into VHS tapes twice if it
happens one more time it will have tied
with lobsters suddenly the existence of
Dr Zoidberg makes sense and him making
sense is a terrifying Prospect when
those other companies aren't braver
foolhardy enough to go trust Planet
Express for Reliable on-time delivery
show predicts Amazon delivering its own
packages almost 15 years before it
happens are there really giant birds
like that no no that was all just
special effects
we don't get more of this storyline
where Professor Farnsworth uses
practical effects against the Studio's
wishes are they saying that aliens are a
gender unto themselves or are they
reducing all aliens to one monolithic
group here for human arousal regardless
of their gender of all the shows that
ask tough questions I expected Futurama
to be the one with the answers earworm
theme songs I know you can't hear it but
it took me a decade to get this one out
of my head the last time and 2033 feels
very very far away caffeinated bacon
baconated grapefruit Admiral crunch
Archduke chocula great now I'm hungry
for foods that don't exist and while I'm
sure Admiral crunch is similar to
Captain Crunch I assure you Archduke
chocula is fundamentally different than
the count death by Sonic diarrhea don't
want that probably not but it can't be
worse than death by Knuckles diarrhea I
intend to do as little dying as possible
jokes on you Leela minimum wage
employees die a little on the inside
with every shift they complete so you
know happy captaining before you go into
space you'll need to see our staff
doctor why you already went to space
during the Island he was fine you just
needed a forced way to introduce
Zoidberg young lady I'm an expert on
humans now pick them out open it and say
the subtitles in my version of the
episode say that the noise Zoidberg
makes is called Lobster crowing but
everyone who googled this a second ago
knows they sound like violins look over
here
tang and
lineman granting said to Netflix
Executives about disenchantment when
Hulu offered to revive Futurama somehow
makes it into the episode nice catch
idiot blaming the receiver when the
passer made a throw I didn't know Bender
played for the Jets and those other
Brave guys no one ever heard of Hey
That's Buzz Aldrin Erasure and I won't
tolerate that he's just as important as
Neil
oh hey uh what's up don't forget Michael
Collins who the is that Amy why
don't you help fry hoist down the crate
then lock up when you're done as we see
her with the group when they go to Luna
Park it is clear that Leela hasn't gone
off on her own so why does she give Amy
the keys here just so they can get lost
inside the crate it's like the story
politely asked Leela for a b plot
Catalyst there are surprisingly few bare
butts on moon Street USA I'll have to
confiscate your alcohol sir better
mascots and you have tried just gonna
ignore the sudden onset of deja vu and
focus on the fact that this park is
paying mascots enough for them to take
their alcohol enforcement Duty seriously
show thinks that when Bender hits the
eye of a George melies homage
I understand everything about moon it's
a well-crafted film which you should not
disparage I guess a robot would have to
be crazy to want to be a folk singer
setting up the story for a possible
future episode instead of focusing on
the episode you're currently in this
this week show just now realizes that
this amusement park pit is in fact
boring in that we're all on the verge of
a nap due to lack of stimuli address all
complaints to the Monsanto corporation
in hindsight Monsanto purchasing a theme
park is probably a better deal than
Bayer purchasing Monsanto that one goes
out too all our fans working in
Acquisitions and mergers I don't care
how educational it is let's do it title
of my sex tape are we really expected to
care about the rest of this episode more
than trying to find out what the
fatalities are in Mortal cooperation
ship Amy and Bender just happened to be
here in the arcade when these stuffed
animals are getting loaded in
show rips off Firefly's use of Chinese
dialect to swear and get past the
sensors what's that this came before
Firefly
well in that case it's a Matt graning
show predicts the future cliche I don't
see you with a fungenering degree the
sadness of realizing that the fungeneers
are making theme park rides instead of
delicious mushroom ravioli we're gonna
die it's every man for himself help me
Leela
damn you Futurama for making me laugh so
hard it's such a simple joke go ahead
take your sim back it's just like making
love you know laugh down rotate 62
degrees engage the rotor I couldn't have
described it better myself leave it to a
machine to be so accurate and precise
and remind our jobs AI is coming for our
dongles and charging ports for amusement
park patrons oh that's a wicked sinful
place oh okay thanks for the assist
stereotypical Moon farmer yes don't be a
touching my three beautiful robot
daughters looks like I made an entire B
plot out of an inappropriate joke I
learned in middle school I wonder if
they'll include that part where I told
my little brother he repeated it to my
mom and I learned that Irish Spring soap
tastes like neither the Irish nor the
spring oh Bender you didn't touch the
crushinator did you of course not a lady
that finally got a romance first I'm
tempted to take a sin off here for
Bender being so body positive but that
unnerves me too much given that it's
Bender so here's a sin for fry judging
Bender's hypothetical sex partners
you're literally your own grandfather
dude show estab publishes mankind
doesn't remember how we reached the moon
in July 1969 but somehow still remembers
the Confederacy which came a century
before that we don't take too kindly to
inconsistency around these parts
hey cool Dark Side of the Moon
forgetting other great Pink Floyd albums
like the wall and animals I really ought
to do something but I am already in my
pajamas when Friday Night comes around
and you suddenly realize you're in your
30s now get in here before you freeze
okay but family under doesn't have
functioning life support inside does it
you will still freeze to death in there
I guess I just wanted you to see it
through my eyes the way I used to
episode takes fry from idiot to
buffoon with a heart of gold but forgets
that he was willing to let Leela die in
quicksand it really is
I don't know why I never noticed before
before probably because this episode
needed a source of conflict and now that
it's almost over we can shift to forcing
this unearned emotional connection this
clever plaque here to explain why the
lunar Landers here on the moon when the
astronauts would have had to return it
when they came back to Earth is clever
but it wasn't in the ship earlier Amy
where'd she learn to operate the
controls like that Lila seems to be
questioning Amy's ability to fly the
ship but then we see Amy working the
Winch just like the claw game because
the episode needs to justify the arcade
side quest so now we are questioning
Amy's ability to fly the ship all they
had to do was write in a reason for her
to play a few rounds of Starfighter to
put our minds at ease
back when you're ready to sing Bacon
pancake
foreign
feeling where my heart is death by
airlock failure death by brain parasites
death by chocolate nowhere special the
Moon the Moon the Moon the Moon Rose
you guys refrigerator magnets
[Music]
the gravity the air the Gophers they
taste terrible
the simulation of a simulation Nightfall
is coming
cool that I'm shivering
for Bender huh now go away or I shall
taunt you a second timer